That's like may six.
I think,
you know,
if,
if Ben asking can really hang with Jordan Burroughs still,
dude,
I,
yeah,
cause everybody who rolls with them.
I've never,
uh,
never even clenched with them.
But everybody who's done everything with him,
like the closest I came to a clinches like that hug you do when you hug a dude
over under a little bit just to feel it out.
But they say that it's like he's got four arms.
They say,
dude,
it's ridiculous.
I've heard Jean Thomas was telling me,
Dean Thomas to St Dude,
it's ridiculous.
Like it doesn't even make sense.
Molly waps world champions.
We all know.
Yeah,
just rag dolls people.
That's how good his wrestling is.
I mean,
if you see that fight,
we,
Robby Lauer the fucking bombs,
that guy tooks fucked up in the fact that he still figured out a way to get
ahold of Robbie Lawler's neck.
Did.
He still figured out a way to get him into that head like once and Robbie knew
he wanted to clench with him.
He couldn't keep them off.
I was sweating in that pike cause you and I hyped him up so much.
I was like,
oh please don't get it starts in the first round.
It's still super controversial ending to me what you had her bond.
Would he say?
Well Herb said that first of all,
herb dean is the shit.
Nice guy.
Couldn't be nicer.
Great Guy.
But I love his perspective.
So laid back and knee,
his ego is so healthy.
Like when he talks about things like you don't see any,
it's very reasoned like a wavy thing,
but he's just like chilled out and he's like very self deprecating and chilled
out about it.
But he had a very good point.
He was like,
that's not just a manipulation of the neck.
Like in terms of like cutting off the carotid artery,
cause like this is a manipulation of the spine.
It's like a,
a bit of a neck crank and he's thinking about that.
He was talking about like,
you look how he's got a hold of the head and how is he goes real.
What I'm concerned with is if someone's going unconscious for from some nerve
shit.
Oh,
wow.
Yeah.
Like from a neck crank,
like apparently he had seen a guy who had gotten neck crank like that.
And then afterwards the guy couldn't walk.
He like couldn't move it came back.
But for moments,
but for moments he couldn't move.
He,
he's the shit we don't even think about.
I'm like,
exactly.
Yeah,
That's why he's herb dean.
He's the gold standard.
He's the gold standards.
Big John McCarthy and him and big John doesn't do it anymore.
So it's hurtful a term to him.
Uno.
And um,
just that when you think about an aspirin says what he says is that,
see that's nasty dude.
That looks terrible.
That's nasty with the way he's holding onto the head like that and cranking your
neck.
I like that.
They're not very bad position.
I like the UFC went.
Oh,
all right.
We're good.
Yeah,
I dig that.
I get it.
I want to see it again.
I like,
I,
I disagree.
I think that,
um,
I I agree with herb stoppage and uh,
I see the,
that the arm went limp but then the thumb came up but then as soon as he let go,
Robbie jumped up.
Uzman had me convinced that Robbie was never out.
But herb had me convinced that it was too dangerous for him to allow to continue
once the arm dropped in that weird way.
Do you side with her?
You have to side with her?
Yeah.
In that situation,
the expert you have to side with herb cause he's right because that is a special
circumstance.
See I looked at it in terms of,
and I didn't even consider this when I was talking to man that I looked at it in
terms of it's just a choke.
Yeah.
Her blue.
No it's a neck crank.
Me Too.
So,
but still I'd love to see it again.
I'd like to see Max.
So if they both win cause asking Mazda doll,
I know that doesn't get your dick hard.
Aspirin,
Mazda dolls one and then let's say asking when's that,
which is tough fight to win.
It's a tough one to say.
Woodley and lawless,
a lot of ones that then they find it's even bigger.